spring snowstorm canceled the
president's schedule but it didn't
affect his Twitter feed one bit
president Trump making no apologies for
congratulating Vladimir Putin on his
election victory I called President
Putin of Russia to congratulate him on
his election victory in past Obama
called him also the fake news media is
crazed because they want me to excoriate
him they are wrong getting along with
Russia and others is a good thing not a
bad thing
president Trump went on to say Russia
can help solve international crises and
he criticized president bush for not
having the smarts to get along with
Russia Obama and Clinton for not having
the energy or chemistry to do it the
president and his chief of staff were
also hot about the leak of a classified
presidential briefing memo on the Putin
phone call
John Kelly said to be frustrated and
disappointed someone leaked that the
memo head do not congratulate in all
caps at the top on Capitol Hill
criticism that the president
congratulated Putin but more concern
about the leak I don't like what he did
but I really hate that there's someone
in his inner circle
White House officials tell Fox News
President Trump may have never seen the
memo in its warning the call to Putin
was made early from the residence just
prior to it HR McMaster and others
briefed the president by phone not in
person
Fox News is told during that conference
call that do not congratulate point
never came up
sources say while the memo was in the
president's daily briefing book he may
not have seen a need to read it since he
was already briefed the Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman says he likely
wouldn't have called Putin at all the
former CIA director a fierce critic of
President Trump said today he believes
the president is afraid of criticizing
Putin the Russians may have something on
him personally that they could always
roll out and make his life more
difficult President Trump also again
took aim at the Malheur investigation
today in a tweet quoting constitutional
law expert Alan Dershowitz his agreement
with the president that Muller should
have never been appointed I think
President Trump was right when he said
there never should have been a special
counsel point because there was no
probable cause one of the president's
biggest supporters on Capitol Hill went
so far as to say Muller should be gone
he's done enough damage he needs to go
I'm not calling for him to be fired
because of all the establishment
Republicans that think they'd have to
come out for Trump if he were fired and
so big news expected to come out of the
White House tomorrow President Trump
expected to announce new tariffs this
time aimed specifically at China these
are being called protective not punitive
tariffs designed to recover damages from
what the president says are China's
unfair trade practices they would be
aimed at a number of goods and could
total 30 billion dollars or more the
president is also expected to announce
investment restrictions in u.s.
technological companies it's believed
that China has tried to capture the
technological either
trees of the future 2017 us-china
Commission report recommended that the
United States restrict investment by
Chinese owned or Chinese government
entities in u.s. technological companies
in order to protect those businesses for
the United States